well can i make you feel better because
i know you're from new york i don't know
this jubilee anything has got you kind
of bummed
um and look i don't you know me i don't
like new york city
mostly because they make fake pace
picante sauce
but i don't like new york city in
general
because new york city no pace is not
from no i said because they make
fake facebook content but there's there
is no fake face
that that entire based on a lie
there is no new york-based salsa company
there is um why would you not have a
salsa factory in mexico
to make you feel better um
one thing that i do like about and i'm
not saying this is a joke i mean
legitimately one thing i do like ab
new york is new york around christmas
time is nice
i i rockefella center and all that stuff
is
is really nice i think they did they
decorate it great it's it's
really awesome new york christmas time
is great i already know what you're
getting at
and i and i love it and i love it and
one of the big
the best things about new york city
during the holidays
is you would agree the tree right
you would grease the tree the the tree
is tree
it's beautiful very nice it's beautiful
like here i want to show you see the
tree this year guys well
before i even do that because i have the
tree here uh
i'm gonna show you the tree last year
okay because i think it's um
i went and saw it last year yeah exactly
and i'm going to show you the
i'm going to show you the tree last year
i'm going to show you what it looks like
i'm going to show you just
how how beautiful the tree was
um in 2019 so this is this is the
this is the tree in uh 2019 here it is
yeah it's really nice right it wasn't
yeah it was look at that
look at that you got to admit man that's
great um
they've received the tree this year and
this is it
um by the way that is not what that tree
looked like when they cut it down
no there was a picture of what it looked
like when they went to go get it and it
was gorgeous and they [ __ ] it up
transporting it
right so um
merry christmas i mean that's like a
legit charlie brown christmas
it is it really is speaking of
the charlie brown thing just reminded me
so apple tv uh apple
bought the rights to all the peanut
stuff like you know the the christmas
stuff and all that stuff
uh but luckily this year they were they
they they're doing the right thing
they're going to because every year like
since i was a kid pbs would show you
know the thanksgiving one and the
christmas one of course it's traditional
well apple was gonna we'll be allowing
allowing them this year to play the
charlie brown wow that's cool man i
guess apple's not an evil corporation
after all
because the good guys that care about
christmas
i think they are evil i mean
oh okay wait a minute you think they're
really good
i think they're evil i mean there were
some people that were being really
[ __ ] gay about that like it is a
tradition and of course
i you know i i love um
the charlie brown specials like i always
watch those you know as a kid but like
or even like as an adult it still goes
on in the background now
when you're doing [ __ ] at least like one
day during christmas you'll have it on
while you're cooking or
whatever the [ __ ] just because it's a
comfort thing
but um some people were being really gay
about it because they were
of course people on the right were
spreading it around and going it's a war
on christmas
they don't want to play him on on the
television anymore and then when the
story kind of got clarified people were
like
well no just apple has the right so like
who the [ __ ] watching tv anymore
like you know what i mean like you know
these things are going to
to shift as technology and as as
innovation emerges
like i'm sure there wasn't like a was
there a christmas radio special that
they used to play back in the day
and then when tv came along they were
like we're never going to have our radio
christmas special anymore and you're
like no it's just on a new thing
it's still here and in my christmas in
my house it was always chris
natural lampoon's christmas vacation
well yeah i mean that was that was the
one then
that we always i mean so to this year i
still watch it around christmas time
yeah that's a big one in a lot of
households i mean i thought our family's
big on that one
um but i don't know man home alone
home alone home alone pretty christmas i
gotta do a home alone i'd rather do a
die hard
if we're doing if we're doing christmas
movies apparently they find an owl
living in that tree
oh and this one that's good
i guess again the killing owls on top of
everything else well i mean
you know gotta have a tree um [ __ ] those
owls
you